llama la atención la cantidad de
personas y de recursos que movilizaron
para un funeral de tal magnitud como
quedará marcado en la historia este
evento y por supuesto la figura de
isabel 2a
qué tal valentina bueno tú lo dijiste en
algún momento y se ha repetido varias
veces a lo largo del día esto es un
momento histórico para la vida de por lo
menos tres generaciones de británicos
que no conocieron otro monarca que no
fuera la reina isabel por otro lado
también quizá un tanto frívolo pero
interesante es ver como los británicos
en 11 días lograron hacer un despliegue
tal con un
decenas de miles de personas presentando
sus respetos ya sea en escocia o en la
misma inglaterra
por la muerte de la reina y en ese
sentido también estamos viendo como la
monarquía hoy día vuelve a estar bajo la
lupa de la opinión pública no solamente
por
la popularidad de la reina isabel sino
que además también las expectativas de
cómo lo va a hacer
el nuevo rey carlos tercero se puede
pensar en algún líder mundial que en la
actualidad genere la misma simpatía y el
mismo interés que generaba la reina
isabel segunda nadie perdón que sea tan
tajante pero nadie o sea tú crees que
alguien
esta cantidad de gente
que tú ves por ejemplo en el long walk
que ustedes están mostrando ahí en
windsurf o que a cerca de 2500 millones
de personas hayan visto esto por
distintas plataformas te puedo decir que
nadie de hecho piensa que hay muchos
gobiernos republicanos que desearían
tener el nivel de popularidad que tiene
la monarquía o la reina entonces
me da la impresión de que nadie podría
equiparar este nivel de atención este
nivel de cariño de respeto y devoción
con el que viene para reino unido con
carlos tercero a la cabeza hemos visto
que quieren mostrarlo como una persona
que se acerca a quien tiene contacto con
la gente pero al mismo tiempo se han
finalizado algunas reacciones o gestos
del nuevo rey que han generado fuertes
críticas
pero fíjate tú que esas críticas vienen
fundamentalmente de gente como nosotros
que no vivimos en el reino unido o por
ejemplo en mi caso que he oído en un
país que lleva dos siglos de república y
en ese sentido a los británicos no les
llama mucho esto la atención no es
simplemente un comercio nunca son un
elemento curioso de la personalidad del
rey el tema es más difícil por la
situación económica y social que vive el
reino unido- en ciernes con una crisis
energética que la va a vivir toda europa
producto de la guerra en ucrania eso es
un tema que va a poner atención en la
monarquía eventualmente porque se
necesita mostrar austeridad y al mismo
tiempo empatía tú tienes razón eso sí
valentina en esta idea de la cercanía no
lo vimos desde el primer día cuando el
rey se baja en buckingham palace a
saludar a la gente entonces en ese
sentido tú te das cuenta de que esos son
los signos que vienen y esos son los
obstáculos y desafíos que se vienen
también